JESSE: WELCOME TO.
"WATTERS' WORLD."
I'M JESSE WATTERS.
THERE WAS A BIG BLOWUP ON THE
VIEW.
MEDICARE, SOCIAL SECURITY, THE
LIBRARY.
>> I HOPE DEMOCRATS DO RUN A
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST BECAUSE YOU
WILL LOSE SPECTACULARLY AND I'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO ELECTION NIGHT
WHERE I GET TO TELL EVERYBODY I
TOLD YOU SO.
I THINK YOU SHOULD START PAYING
YOU SHOULD.
IT'S DANGEROUS.
JESSE: PASSIONS ARE RUNNING HIGH
BECAUSE A SOCIALIST RISING STAR
KNOCKED OFF PELOSI'S PROTEGE.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
STUMBLED THROUGH WEEKS OF
GAFFES.
>> THIS SOCIALIST LABEL IS
SOMETHING THE MEDIA CALLS MORE
ABOUT.
I DON'T KNOCK ON A PERSON'S DOOR
AND SAY HEY, LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT SOCIALISM.
IT'S NOT THANK YOU I CAMPAIGN.
IT'S FOX NEWS AND THE MEDIA
WANTS TO CONTINUE USING THIS
WORD.
BY ME SAYING NO, I'M NOT, IT
BECOMES A DISTRACTION.
JESSE: VENEZUELA, A RICH COUNTRY
WITH BLOUNTFUL NATURAL RESOURCES
IS NOW A HELL HOLE.
LOOK AT WHAT THE EXPERIMENT WITH
SOCIALISM HAS WROUGHT.
NEARLY 90% NOW LIVE IN POVERTY.
THE AVERAGE PERSON LAST 24
POUNDS LAST YEAR.
SIX PEOPLE ARE -- SICK PEOPLE
ARE TAKING DOG MEDICINE.
DELAYS MASSIVE TOILET PAPER
SHORTAGE AND IT'S THE MURDER
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD.
DO THEY WANT TO DESTROY AMERICA?
THEY SAY WE MEAN SCANDINAVIAN
COUNTRIES, THAT'S WHERE
SOCIALISM WORKS.
THE SCANNED NAICHIAN SOCIALIVE
SUCCESS STORY IS A FANTASY.
YOU KNOW WHAT COUNTRY IS DOING
BETTER THAN SWEDEN?
SWITZERLAND.
SWEDEN WAS GOING OFF A CLIFF
UNTIL A DECADE AGO WHEN
CONSERVATIVES TOOK OVER AND
IMPLEMENTED CAPITALIST REFORMS.
THE SCANDINAVIA DEFEAT THE
NAZIS, PUT A MAN ON THE MOON,
TO HUMANKIND FROM SCANDINAVIA?
IKEA.
YOU RAISE TAXES ON EVERYBODY IN
AMERICA AND IT WON'T MAKE A DENT
IN PAYING THAT BILL.
IF SOCIALISTS DON'T TRUST TRUMP
WHY GIVE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN CHARGE YOUR
LIFE.
YOU WANT TRUMP TALS YOUR
LANDLORD AND RUNNING TOUR
COLLEGES?
I THOUGHT DIDN'T LIKE TRUMP
UNIVERSITY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS A
HARD ENOUGH TIME TAKING CARE OF
OUR VETS AND SECURING OR BORDERS